-We'll be right back
with a performance from
Regard, Troye Sivan, Tate McRae.
Stick around, everybody.
-♪♪ Four and three
and two and one... ♪♪
-Thank you for coming
on "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate this.
This is always fun for us.
-It is fun.
-Thank you.
Did you have to do -- Did you do
the COVID test and everythin
to get into --
-I would say
the last three or four day
have been medical days
involved with this.
Because this
used to be a TV network.
It's now a medical facility.
-They have to do that. Yes
-And, first,
a nurse comes to your house.
-Yeah. That's correct.
-Yeah.
To do, like,
the major COVID test, you know
which is, like --
goes into your brain.
And then there's
several other COVID tests.
And then people keep
calling you, telling you,
and you have to wait, okay
-Yes.
-So, first, there was a call
which is, you know,
"You're negative."
Then today when I arrived here
I had another COVID test.
-That's right.
-And with --
Many other people had them
So, they're very concerned
about COVID.
You have to go into a COVI
waiting room, which is packed!
[ Laughter ]
It's just as crowded as, like,
the Delta departure lounge
You know,
which is always crowded
'cause no Delta flight
has ever departed, so...
[ Laughter ]
You sit there, and then
after you do all these things,
waiting, a woman came,
and she said --
She stood very far away from me.
And she said,
"Miss Lebowitz, I'm --"
Whatever her name is.
"I am the COVID
compliance officer."
And I believed her
because she did look official.
And she said,
"Just the first thing
I want to tell you is
don't touch Fallon."
-That's not true!
-It's true.
I have many witnesses.
I thought I didn't hear her.
I said, "I'm sorry?"
I thought I didn't hear he
because she has so many things
over her mouth.
So I said -- She said,
"Don't touch Fallon."
I said,
"I will restrain myself."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
"Don't touch Fallon"?
-"Don't touch Fallon."
-Wow.
-Which I think would make
a fantastic bumper sticker
-Thank you.
I'm all about expanding
and going into
different things, yes.
So, good. So you did all
the things, and everything -
-And I wouldn't think
of touching you.
And I never have.
I said, "Really? Like..."
-We've known each other fo
years. We've never touched
-I've never touched.
-No.
We barely look at each other
when you come on.
Yes, exactly.
But everything's fine.
You're negative.
-I am negative.
The million COVID tests
I've had in the past year,
they call and say,
"Fran, your test came back
You're negative."
And I always say, "I knew that."
And they always say,
"How did you know?"
And I say, "Because my entir
life people have been saying
to me,
'Fran, you're so negative.'"